يبدو ان اخبار نهايه العام الماضي ما عم
تختلف عن اخبار بدايه العام الجديد فشفنا
انه في نوفمبر اعلنت شركه تكنولوجيا
العملاقه امازون انها بتخطط لتسريح 10,000
موظف ولكن اللي صار انه الاخبار اليوم
اختلفت بس مش من ناحيه التسريح لا بل من
ناحيه العدد فالشركه اعلنت عن ما يمكن
تسميته بمجزره امازون وانها بتخطط لتسريح
18000 موظف من ما تاجرها امازون جو وقسم
الموارد البشريه وطبعا يعتبر اكبر عمليات
تسريح في تاريخ الشركه العملاقه ولكن ما
تم الاعلان عن الدوله اللي راح يشملها
وقيل انه فقط في دول اوروبيه وبالنسبه
للاسباب التي اجبرت الشركه على اتخاذ هذا
القرار فتحدث رئيس الشركه اندريس انه بسبب
الوضع الاقتصادي غير المؤكد انه خلال فتره
وباء كرونه والناس كانت فيها ببيوتك كان
معظم عمليات الشتاء تتم عبر الانترنت
وباعداد كبيره جدا وبالتالي الان وب
الانكماش الاقتصادي وغلاء تكلفه المعيشه
وتخفيض العملاء لانفاقهم فلازم يكون في
استغناء عن بعض الموظفين بحلول 18 يناير
الحالي وكانت الشركه طبعا توقفت عن تعيين
الموظفين خلال العام الماضي واتخذت خطوات
لاغلاق بعض من اعمالها والغاء مشاريع مثل
روبوت التوصيل الشخصي ومشاهدنا لازم
نذكركم انه مش بس امازون عم بتخطر للتسيح
فمن قبل كان ماته وسناب شات ومايكروسوفت
وجوجل واكيد ما راح ننسى التسريح اللي خرب
الدنيا تصيح موظفي تويتر
عن هذه المجزره الوظيفيه المرتقبه تنضم
الينا من عمان الدكتوره رولا عواد خبيره
الهندسه البشريه اهلا بك استاذه رولا
حدثينا عن هذه المشكله في امازون وهل كان
ذلك متوقعا بعد كرونا
يعطيكم الف عافيه هلا هي هاي المجزره اكيد
ما كانت متوقعه بالطريقه هذه ولكن التخبط
اللي كان موجود وعدم ااا يعني وضوح الطريق
او الخريطه لا هذه الشركات هي اللي ادت
لها المجزره هاي عم بتوصلها لهذا المكان
التخبط هذا هو ما كان متوقع للمرحله نهايه
المرحله المتقدمه هاي وهذا طبعا رح يؤدي
سلبا همم يعني همم بامكان الشركات او حتى
على الاقتصاد العالمي بشكل عام
وهذه الشركات عم شوف انه كبرها الشركات
الهايتك امازون جوجل
اكثر شيء عم بتواجه تحديات وعم بتعان
هالايام هل فينا نقول انه هي وصلت للبيكت
تبعه وتضر وتبعه وهلا راح تشهد عمليات
تقليص ام هي فرحه مرحله مؤقتا
لا هي مرحله خلينا نحكي انها مؤقته ومش
مرحله مش البيك يعني هي ما وصلت البيت وعم
تخسر ولكن هي مرحله بتمر فيها بعد التخبط
اللي صار من الوباء اللي صابنا اللي هو
الكونا صعب الشركات صعب الاقتصاد والازمه
الاقتصاديه اللي حطت بعد ذلك هو سبب سببها
وهذا كله بيادي يعني همم انهيار النظام
الراسمالي وبيادي كثير اشياء راح تكون
سلبا على المجتمع الانساني يعني ممكن انه
ترجع عنا لبريتال البريتانيا الحديثه غير
هيك ممكن كمان يعني نحكي انه في شركات راح
تندمج مع بعضها في شركات رح تخسر همم يعني
همم راح تخسر الوظائف اللي موجوده عندها
او حتى هتخسر وجودتها وكان يونتها
بالاقتصاد العالمي وهون عم نحكي عنهيار
لا انظمه ووجود انظمه جديده
يعني وضوح الرؤيه بالنسبه لهم بالطريقه
الصحيحه واكبر دليل على ذلك انهم اليوم عم
بروحوا قسم الموارد البشريه اللي هو خلينا
نحكي ااه يعني الرئه الرقبه المسؤوله عن
تحريك الجسد اللي هو الشركات الموجوده في
العالم ما بصير احنا نحكي انه قسم كامل
بدير يعني هو مسؤول عن اداره القوى
العامله همم بنحكي انه بدنا نروحه ما في
له داعي وما له ذلك هون عم نحكي عن سوء
اداره سوء تخطيط وعلى همم يعني همم زي ما
حكينا راح يؤدي للبروليتاريا وراح يؤدي
الى المواطن العالميه بسبب يعني انعدام
وجود بعض الشركات واندماج البعض الاخر
عواد خبيره الهندسه البشريه شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]